- You know, I think
everything is my fault?
Like all of it.
There has never been a
better time to be alive
in the human race than right now.
When it's shit around you,
you have to make it positive in your head.
(sibilant noise)
- Need motivation?
- Watch a Top 10 with Believe Nation.
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
I believe in you and
this channel is designed
to be a part of your daily success routine
so let's get your motivation to a 10
and get you believing in you.
Grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who went from
being born in the Soviet Union
and selling lemonade and
baseball cards growing up
to wanting to become the
greatest entrepreneur
of our generation.
He's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules of
Success, Volume Nine.
Also, if you want to know what Gary V
and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence,
check out my 254 Confidence
Series where everyday
for the next 254 days,
I will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence.
The link to join is in
the description below.
- The reason people aren't patient
is they value other
people's opinions too much.
(upbeat music)
- Okay, let's kick it
off with rule number one,
take on responsibility.
- The reason I say the thing
that if there's anybody
that ever looked like you that made it,
then there's no excuse,
is because I believe it.
You know, it's really
hard, you're in an argument
and your friend tells
you, that's great, Gary,
but both my parents were alcoholics
and that really (bleeped) me up.
Right, now your on the defense.
That's a good first punch by them.
I'm like, cool, we don't need to use me.
If anybody has ever been successful
that had two alcoholic parents,
which by the way, I know of three,
well then, now what's your excuse, Karen?
We're just so interested
in blaming everybody else
and excuses because we don't
want to take on responsibility.
And somewhere a long time
ago I went completely,
I only take, you know, I
think everything is my fault?
Like all of it.
Like I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now
and not nice out, my fault.
(audience chuckling)
Like his scar, my fault.
Like I just default into my fault.
And everybody tries to do
everything else the other way.
And let me tell you how good life becomes
when you take on responsibility.
It gets real good.
Some of you, and there's a
lot of you that follow me,
you know why I keep bringing that up,
the last scene of Eight
Mile, the Eminem movie?
How many people have seen that movie?
Great.
The last scene, they go into the battle,
he makes fun of himself the whole time
because it leaves the
other person with nothing.
The leverage is in being
accountable of everything.
The leverage is exposing your weaknesses.
I proudly talk about
passing on Uber twice,
being a D and F student.
I proudly talk about
my shortcomings, right?
I can't wait for more
bad things to happen.
I mean it.
Because I will talk about them.
Because, what, you're so perfect?
You.
- Rule number two, be practical.
- We are in a remarkable time.
For all the things you may
be worried about left, right,
up, down, there has never
been a better time to be alive
in the human race than right now.
Medicine, life expectancy, poverty,
every issue we have, better.
The best people to talk about
what's going on in America
are 90-year-olds, they on everybody.
(audience laughing)
They're like, this bad, ah, pff.
This woman made me laugh so hard.
This like 92-year-old woman
stopped me in the street
and she's like keep
doing what you're doing.
I'm like, she looked like 190.
(audience laughing loudly)
I was like, thank you.
I got to talk to her for
a second and she's like,
and by the way, these women,
and she's wrong but it was still funny,
she goes, these women,
if I didn't have somebody grab
my ass everyday in the office
I was pissed!
I was like, I get it, I get it.
(audience laughing loudly)
I was like, I get it.
I was like, don't say that in public.
She was like, the public.
(audience laughing loudly)
I was like, man, 92 is some gangster.
I'm obsessed with practicality.
People think I'm a destructor
or, you know, Nostradam-,
predictor, right?
I'm practical.
Facebook and Instagram ads
are grossly under-priced.
If you go home tonight and Google
how to run Instagram story
ads and learn how to do that
and then make a video or picture
and run Instagram story ads
for whatever you're trying to do in life,
become the mayor here, sell
some peanuts, kombucha,
get people to sign up for your track team.
I don't care what.
I don't know where the this comes from.
(audience laughing loudly)
I didn't even think you
could sign people up
for a track team.
Anyway, nonetheless.
(audience laughing loudly)
An Instagram story ad will work better
than anything else you can do
if you care about people 15-55.
Fifteen to 45.
If you care about people 30-75,
Facebook works better than anything.
Like, all your dreams,
whatever that may be,
simple dreams like
making $400 more a month
so you can save it
and take your family to
Walt Disney this year.
All your dreams.
The amount of people that are affected
by making $200 more a month is staggering.
The fact that I know that if you literally
stopped listening to me right
now, took out your phone,
went to Craigslist, went
to the For Sale section,
clicked on the Free section
within the For Sale section,
took your car, got up,
left in the middle of my keynote,
and picked up eight things, went home,
took one picture on your phone,
not like in the old days where the phone,
you take the disc out and
put it in your computer.
(audience laughing)
No, not that.
Which is, oh, by the way, the old days,
you know, 11 years ago.
(audience laughing)
No, just take a picture of the thing
and post it on Facebook Marketplace
and post it for $20-$80,
that literally in the next 48 hours,
you would have $200 more.
I'm obsessed with practicality.
Everything I talk about feels so real,
it just might take 11 years
and a lot of people don't have 11 years.
They don't have 11 years
because they're not willing
to put in the work to be happy
for the rest of their life.
They'd rather complain, they'd
rather blame somebody else.
- Rule number three, love the game.
- What are the qualities that you think
make for a true and a
successful entrepreneur?
What's important?
- Sheer he has to love the game.
For me, a purebred entrepreneur,
she or he loves the journey
not the stuff.
You know, one of the
things I struggle with
in the current state of
entrepreneurship is a lot of people
want the vacations,
the watches,
even in the context of this,
you guys have such an incredible imagery,
I think it's remarkable.
Who doesn't want fine things in life?
- Yeah.
- But I think that if you're in the game
just for the fine things
in life, for the bottles
and the models and the private planes,
I think you're going to lose.
And it definitely is not my
definition of an entrepreneur.
My definition of an entrepreneur
is somebody who can't live
without doing their thing
and trying to create,
literally suffocated.
- Rule number four, find your why?
- People quit all the time
because if they're doing it for the money,
I think the bigger question is
what do you want the money for?
Is it blocking and insecurities,
is it to get the girl,
is it because you're trying
to amass as much as you can
so you actually don't like
working and you want to live a.
The really so many people
fail in life and business
is their model is let me
get the money so that I can
enjoy and relax.
They think of it as like hoarding it
and then eating it all over time.
It's like retirement and all this stuff.
It's such a bad way to think about it
because then you're feeling
the pressure of like amassing
so that you can then enjoy.
I think the bigger question
is like what are you up to?
Like why are you doing it?
Like what's up?
I just think a lot of people
are trying to achieve success
and use fame or money as
make-up for a situation
that they're just not happy about.
Like you have to figure
out how to make your day-in
and day-out happy.
- Rule number five, surround
yourself with positivity.
- My dad's an asshole, right?
- Okay.
Because financially we're broke, right?
- Yeah.
- So he holds all of the
financial power over us.
- Yeah, yep.
- What can I do?
I want to excel in life.
- You've got to break out of that pattern.
You've got to not listen
to him and make money
in however way you want.
Listen, otherwise you're stuck.
If you want to help your mom,
sometimes the best way to
help your mom is to get out
and then come back and get her out.
- I'm only 14, I can't do shit.
- I get it.
So honestly, honestly, and I respect that,
listen to me, life is long.
You're in a spot right
now but my mom didn't have
her mom or dad at 14.
Life is long.
It sucks right now.
When you're 14, it feels
like it's your life, forever.
It's not your life forever, bro.
You understand?
Just surround yourself
with as much positivity
to get you through this chapter.
- I just can't do that.
I have no friends.
- I get it bro.
Bro, you've got to be patient.
It's early.
- I know, it's just forever man.
I can't take this.
- I get it but you have to understand
there's no alternative.
There's only two choices here.
You stay under that roof and you eat
for four more years, three
more years, two more years,
or you bounce now.
Plenty of people bounced at 14.
It's not common in the
UK but people do it.
Or you don't.
Life's about a very simple option.
You either do or you don't.
If you're going to eat under that roof,
you need to put your ear pods in
and listen to positivity 24/7
to get you through that.
Do you understand?
When your surroundings are,
your inside's got to be positive.
The fact that you're even here
means you're halfway home.
- All right, thanks man.
- You're welcome.
I wish you well, man.
Hit me up anytime.
DM me, all right?
All right?
You listening?
Listen to me, listen to
me, when it's around you,
you have it make it positive in your head.
I know it feels like it's forever
and it's going to take
forever and when you're 14
four more years sounds like forever,
but you have no choice.
You either bounce or you stay.
And if you stay, which is
more likely, which is fine,
you've got to put positivity in your ears.
Do you understand?
I promise you.
You have no other alternatives.
Otherwise you just dwell
and you go down a spiral
that you don't want to go down.
You understand?
- Rule number six, live your passion.
- By the way, this whole notion
of like you can do anything
and all this stuff, let me just
tell you, it's stupid hard.
Reality is, most of you are
just averagely talented.
Right?
Like, you're not going to
over-index in anything too crazy.
Here's the good news.
This is not about how much money you make
or how talented you are,
this is about being happy.
Everybody here, regardless of how talented
they are in making money
or art or what have you,
has that they're super into.
You love Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles?
Your whole life could
be about Michelangelo.
(audience laughing loudly)
It could.
And here's what really with me.
In this internet age,
you could have a podcast
around Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,
you could buy Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle memorabilia
on Craigslist and Facebook and Etsy
and then flip it on a different platform
because you're so knowledgeable
because that's the pizza-eating Leonardo.
(audience laughing)
That I'm just fascinated
about what happens
when you go all in on your passion
and you're committed to it
and you use the infrastructure of this.
You, living your life for 80 years
as the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle expert
is getting funnier to me by the second.
(audience laughing loudly)
Making $83K a year in ads
on your podcast, the flip,
some reckless reason
somebody paid you $2000
to go to a Bush League Comic-Con thing.
(audience chuckling)
That person making $62,000 a year
being the TMT expert
versus them making $77,000
a year being an admin
in a company where they hate
their life nine to five.
That delta is something
I will go to the grave on
because it is what I want
to articulate to everybody.
The unbelievable level
of practicality to do
around stuff you like
and here's the big part.
How many people under 40?
Let me just start with this group.
If you just really took
what I'm talking about,
became an expert at
Facebook and Instagram,
really understood,
the fact that you could
take a leap for two years,
move back in home, move in
together, cut your expenses.
I don't give a.
The fact that you can do
that for two or three years
and if it doesn't work out,
you can go back to getting a job,
that's nuts.
That's nuts.
- Rule number seven,
reinvest in your business.
- I don't think you get to judge
what somebody does with
the fruits of their labor.
- Yeah.
- For me, I think that
that's what's amazing
about anything, which is
there's many different,
many different definitions.
For you, you know, go out,
work your face off, win,
and reward yourself with
something is exactly right.
For me, the reward is pouring
more of the dollars and energy
into the company, not
buying stuff for myself.
It's one and the same.
- Yeah.
- It's one and the same.
To me, I think it's
amazing if somebody wants
to buy an Armani suit
or a $5000 pair of belt
or a diamond ring for $100,000.
I don't but that doesn't
mean that's right or wrong.
What I'm doing with that same
$100,000, instead of a ring,
is I'm hiring two more
people because I'm trying
to buy the jewelry company,
not a piece of the jewelry.
- Rule number eight,
don't care about the judgments of others.
- The biggest vulnerability
everybody has here
is they're worried about
somebody else's judgment.
The reason there is no moment of clarity
is you don't want to jump.
You don't want to jump because
you're worried if you lose
what people are going to say,
starting with your parents,
your friends, your contemporaries.
My ability to not truly, truly care about
other people's opinions
has been the foundation of my happiness.
I respect people's opinions, I just,
I just don't care about
their judgment of me.
I have flip-flopped
about project management
at Vayner Media like so many times
and I don't worry if somebody
here is like make a decision
or like you're stupid or like what the
or why are we always changing?
Like, go work at Gray Advertising.
- Rule number nine, have selfless goals.
- The reason I will never achieve my goals
is my goals are to play.
The reason people achieve their goals
is because their goals
was a number of money.
If your goal is an amount
of money, you've lost.
The reason it's empty is what?
You wanted to be a millionaire,
so what happens next?
You're going to make $10 million a year,
like what $100 million?
It's the wrong goals.
My biggest goals is to be the
most impactful entrepreneur
of this generation by
bringing the most value
to all the entrepreneurs.
That's going to take me my whole life.
(audience applauding)
- [Male] Thank you.
- So you need to change your goal
from something that's selfish
to something that's selfless
because then it will take
you the rest of your life.
- And rule number 10, the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is live life without regrets.
- You should really go to
a retirement home one day
and volunteer and just talk to them.
It will make you want to do
every minute of your life
because when you're 90
and you're not mobile and
you're tired and it's over,
you can't do anything, you can't do it.
You can't build that company you wanted,
you can't spend that time with your kid.
It's regret.
And it drives the out me.
How old are you?
- I'm 27, 27.
- You got time.
It's a balance of regret and patience.
- Okay.
- Look, you can go hard for
three years, do nothing right,
wake up, and be young as.
The amount of people who
are watching this right now,
maybe even in this room,
that are sad, men and women,
that they didn't go for it
and didn't make the move
and didn't try, that regret
is a hell of a lot longer
and more painful and more drawn out
than the instant
rejection of going for it.
It's just the way it is.
Like, even if you think
of random dumb stuff
like not asking out that person
in high school or something,
this stuff lingers.
It's the stuff that you
don't do that bothers you
and so for the purebred
entrepreneurs in here
that haven't decided to make that leap
or take that at-bat, I implore
you to do so right away
because this window closes too.
- Now I've got a really
special bonus clip from Gary V
on how to hold yourself accountable
that I think you're going to really enjoy.
But before that, it's time
for the three-point landing questions.
It's time to move from
just watching another video
to actually taking action in
your business and your life.
So here we go.
Question number one, what is your why?
Number two, how can you surround yourself
with more positivity today?
And number three, what is one regret
that you need to let go of?
- Happiness is the KPI not buying stuff,
not having a lot of followers,
not being a successful CEO.
Happiness.
And happiness never happens
when you're fronting,
when it's fake.
So my friends, listen, be patient.
One of the biggest reasons
so many people are upset
is they don't even realize
they're in a fake environment.
They don't realize that they
have developed the grind
or the hustle, or the patience
because things have been
subsidized for whatever reason.
It could be a million different things.
But often parents pander.
Or I'll give you another fake environment,
just living in a glass half-empty world.
Before you started, you
lost because you decided
you can't win, or the government's up,
or the game is rigged,
or it's not for you.
Somebody put into your
head that you can't win,
that it's not fair, that there's no shot.
Another fake environment.
You own your.
You can do this.
But the reality is you
have to get real serious
about a couple of things which is
really putting yourself when you realize
you're fundamentally 100% in control.
You get real happy when
you realize you're control.
Accountability my friends.
Accountability trumps entitlement
in the game of happiness,
which leads to 100% success on your terms.
- Raise your standard!
- Apple, at the core, its core value,
is that we believe that
people with passion
can change the world for the better.
- Not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your acceptance of me.
- If you like this video
check out the one we did
on the power of habit.
I think you're going to really enjoy it.
It's right next to me.
Continue to believe
and I'll see you there.
- We are what we purely do.
- Change doesn't just happen
at this level of behavior.
But what you have to
change the environment.
- Make a damn schedule!
(sibilant noise)